[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اعلن الكرملين ان الهجمات
التي شنتها سفن حربيه روسيه من اسطول بحر
قزوين على مواقع في سوريا تمت بالتنسيق مع
شركائها العراقيين والايرانيين والسوريين
في مركز التنسيق الاستخباري في بغداد
نتوقف مع هذا الموضوع لنناقش في
محورين ما طبيعه الدور الحالي للتحالف
الروسي العراقي الايراني
السوري وهل ثمه قلق امريكي من انطلاق
صواريخ روسيه من قباله سواحل ايران عابره
اجواء
[موسيقى]
العراق تزامنا مع شن اربع سفن حربيه روسيه
من اسطول بحر قزوين ضربات على مواقع في
سوريا تقول موسكو انها تابعه لتنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه بالتزامن مع هذا جاء
الاعلان عن تعاون ذي صله بين الشركاء في
مركز التنسيق الاستخباري ومقره الدولي
الدوري الحالي بغداد ليطرح علامات استفهام
حول حجم وطبيعه التحالف الروسي العراقي
الايراني السوري وقد اظهرت صور عبور اثنين
من الصواريخ المنطلقه من بحر قزوين اجواء
العراق وهنا سؤال جديد الن تعمق اجواء
العراق اذا فتحت للروس بواعث قلق واشنطن
تقرير مريم ابيش يطرح اشكالات نناقشها مع
ضيوف
حلقتنا في الحمله الروسيه على السوريا
هناك ما قبل القصف من بحر قزوين وما بعده
لم يخفي الكريملن ان العمليه تتم بالتنسيق
مع مركز بغداد لتنسيق الاستخبارات
والشركاء في الحلف الفتي المعروف بالرباعي
اعلان موسكو توضيح اخر ان التنسيق لم يعد
استخباراتيا فحص بين الدول الاربع وانما
بفتح اجواء واراضي الدول المعنيه للروس
وسلاحهم حتى الان تكتفي روسيا بالعمل جوا
وبحرا بصواريخها يصل مداها 1500 كومر على
الاقل هذا هو المعلن رسميا يشار الى ان ما
تعرف بالخليه الاستخباراتيه ومركزها بغداد
تضم سته مستشارين عسكريين من كل دوله عضو
في التحالف وهي روسيا والعراق وسوريا
وايران يفترض ان تكون رئاسه الخليه دوريه
كل ثلاثه اشهر ما يؤشر الى ان التدخل
العسكري الروسي سيطول وربما لن يتوقف في
سوريا لم يخفي رئيس الوزراء حيدر العبادي
رغبته في الوجود الروسي في العراق ولكنه
متردد في طلب ذلك رسميا خشيه غضب حليفه
الامريكي حليف تشكك بغداد في السر والعنان
في جديه ضربته الجويه المستمره منذ اكثر
من عام بهدف القضاء على تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه البروباجاندا المواليه للتحالف
الرباعي تسارع في الجزم بان الضربات
الروسيه في سوريا تحقق
اهدافها ليس صحيحا تقول المعارضه السوريه
وحتى واشنطن تفيد مصادر المعارضه ان
الضربات الروسيه استهدفت مواقع للجيش الحر
ومدنيين في حلب تحديدا واشنطن من جهتها
تقول ان 90% من تلك الضربات لم تكن ضد
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه تاخذ الحمله روسيه
ابعادا اكبر جغرافيا وسياسيا وسط صمت
امريكي يقول الكثير ماذا يسكت الرئيس
اوباما استنادا لصحيفه الواشنطن بوست فان
التدخل الروسي يضع الرئيس الامريكي امام
خياري الرد العملي او الرضخ وكشفت الصحيفه
ان ثمه قلقا من عدم اتخاذ اوباما اجراءات
حاسمه فورا لان ذلك سيلحق اضرارا كبيره
بسمعه الولايات المتحده وسياستها الخارجيه
وجهودها في مكافحه الارهاب اما صحيفه لوس
انجلس تايمز فقالت صراحه اوباما هو ابرز
الخاسرين من تصعيد بوتين العسكري وتضيف
الصحيفه ان دعم بوتين للاسد جعل البيت
الابيض يبدو ضعيفا
ومتردده الموقف الامريكي الاخير و بالاحرى
اللام موقف وانعكاس لسياسه التردد
والتناقض واللا حسم التي انتهجتها اداره
اوباما على مدى سنوات الثوره السوريه لذلك
لم يكن عسيرا على القيصر ان يستغل ذلك
الفراغ الدبلوماسي العسكري رجل الكي جي بي
سابقا معروف انه يتقن اكثر من رياضه ولكن
حتى الان لا يعرف اذا كان يجيد السباحه
لدرجه الخروج من المستنقع السوري
سالما معنا في هذه الحلقه من موسكو السيد
اندري ستيبانوف الخبير في شؤون الشرق
الاوسط ومن واشنطن السيد جيف جوردون
المسؤول السابق في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
ومن لندن الكاتب الصحفي السوري بسام
الجعار مرحبا بكم جميعا والسؤال للسيد
اندري ستيبانوف سيد اندريس ستيبانوف عندما
ينشر موقع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه رسما
بيانيا يوضح انطلاق الصواريخ الست والعش
من اربع سفن حربيه في بحر قزوين مرورا
باجواء العراق وايران تفاديا للاجواء
التركيه والاذرع او الاذربيجانيه هل نحن
بازاء مجرد حلف استخباري ام حلف عسكري
كامل الاركان ربما له ادوار كبيره لم يعلن
عنها
بعد لا ظن ان تم انشاء المركز المعلوماتي
في بغداد ا يدم اربع اعضاء روسيا وايران
والعراق وسوريا وكانت هذه الخطوه كرد
الفعل
لعجز التحالف الدولي تحت القياده
الامريكيه
على رادع زحف الداعش على اراضي العراقيه
وعلى اراضي السوريه
وطبعا هناك يعني تبادل النشيط بال
المعلومات بين اربعه الاطراف لهذا الماركس
واذون ان بعض الاهداف تم تحديدها يعني انا
لا ادري ان كنت تنظر جيدا للخطه السوريه
ام لا سيد ستيبانوف لكن الهجمات كما هو
معلن هي في ريف حماه هي في سهل الغاب في
اللاذقيه وفي ادلب ولا نعلم ان هناك وجودا
قويا لتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في هذه
المناطق جنب
را وجنب
راقه وجن براقه طبعا يعني ت اختيار
الاهداف ل
تمركز
القوات
لفصله الارهابيه مثل الداعش مثل جبهه
النصره احرار الشام
و جيش الاسلام والى اخرها ولكن في الحقيقه
انا الشوك في جدوى استخدام هذه الصواريخ
المجنحه ضد الاهداف في سوريا يعني ممكن
اصابه تلك الاهداف بسهوله من خلال طيران
طيرات يعني بواسطه الطيرات اظن ان اطلاق
هذه الصواريخ كانت الرساله موجهه الى
الغرب اكثر منها موجهه الى سوريا سي
نعم هذه نقطه مهمه نه
مهم السيد جيف جوردون هل فهم الغرب هذه
الرساله هل تلقيتم
الرساله مرحبا يا
مكمور اعتقد بان الغرب يشعر بقلق كبير
حيال ما تقوم به روسيا فنحن نعتبر بشار
الاسد هو الاخر ارهابي من الواضح اننا
نحاول تقويض وتحجيم تنظيم الدوله لكننا
ايضا في الغرب نؤكد في امريكا واوروبا
بضروره رحيل الاسد لانه ما دام بشار في
الحكم فستستمر الحرب الاهليه حاليا هناك
مئات الالاف قتلي ونصف سوريون نازحون بما
فيهم اربعه ملايين خارج البلد هؤلاء
اللاجئون والمهاجرون يؤدون الى عدم
استقرار في اوروبا مما يؤدي بالمانيا الى
مواجهه دول اوروبا الاخرى اذا الغرب يشعر
باليا
وبقلق بشان ما يقوم به بوتن الذين اعتبره
يخدم المصالح الروسيه لان قاعدته الوحيده
موجوده في سوريا خارج الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابق هذا اولا ثانيا بشار الاسد يشتري
ملايين ينفق ملايين من الدولارات على
الاسلحه الروسيه ونعتقد ايضا بان بشار
الاسد لا يحاول القضاء على تنظيم الدوله
ف من استهدفهم اولا هما المعارضه حتد الى
مثل الجيش الحر حيث ان الجيش الحر موجود
في حماس حمص وحما والنظام لا يستهدف مناطق
خارج ذلك اذا النظام يحاول ان يغش العالم
وروسيا تحاول البقاء على هذا النظام هذا
الدكتاتور الذي تعرفه امريكا انه يدعم حزب
الله والذي هو منظمه ارهابيه ويدعم ايران
والتي يحكمها نظام ارهابي اذا نحن في
امريكا نشعر بقلق بالغ حيال ما تقوم به
روسيا ونشعر بقلق اننا قد نواجه مشكله اذا
لا نقوم
بتنسيق الاجواء فوق سوريا لان هناك الكثير
من الدول تقوم بحلا عفوا على المقاطعه
عفوا على المقاطعه سيد جيف جوردون ايا يكن
تصوركم لما يجري حاليا لكن الروس لديهم
منطق يتمثل في ان الامريكيين رغم ضرباتهم
المستمره على تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه منذ
شهور وربما مده تفوق العام لم تؤثر في هذا
التنظيم وانما صار يتمدد كما يقول شعاره
باق ويتمدد لماذا الصواريخ الامريكيه
فعاله
ضد العراق واسقطت نظام صدام حسين في شهر
واحد ولماذا هي فعاله ضد نظام القذافي اذا
عدنا بالزمن الى الوراء قليلا وليست فعاله
ضد تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه وهو في النهايه
او في التحليل الاخير تنظيم مجرد تنظيم
مسلح وجه نظري انه مد الطويل علينا ان
نعرف المشاكل الحقيقيه وبالتالي علينا ان
نرى انه لا من السهل ان نلقي بال اللائم
على اوباما او بوش لانه منذ السبعينات من
القرن الماضي كانت هناك حرب الوكاله بين
الشيعه وايران من ناحيه والسنه ومثلنا في
السعوديه وهذا هذا الخلاف كان وراء حرب
العراقيه الايرانيه واجتياح العراق وكذلك
محاوله امريكا الاطاحه بصدام اذا الكثيرون
يودون القاء اللائم على امريكا وان ذلك
خطاها لا الامر اكثر تعقيدا في سوريا
والعراق هذه المجموعات تحاول ان تقتل
بعضها البعض نتيجه لحرب طائفيه فن واجه
العرب يواجهون الاكراد والسنه ضد الشيعه
اعتقد انه يجب ان ننظر الى سوريا والعراق
مثل يوغسلافيا وان نقسم هذه البلدان حتى
يتمكن الشيعه والاكراد والسنه من الحصول
على دولهم الصغيره فيما يتعلق بسوريا
اعتقد ان الكثير اعتقد ان هناك امكان وجود
دوله
علويه قابله للحياه واذا تمكنا ايضا ان
نفصل السنه في منطقه الانبار حد تنظيم
الدوله وقتها يمكن ان نقدم الدوله للاكراد
ونعطي للسنه معظم الاراضي السوريه
بالاضافه الى ذلك بينما نترك للشيعه مناطق
من سوريا ولبنان اعتقد ان هذا هو الحل
الحقيقي ولا نقم فقط بتاسيس بعض المناطق
حاضره الجو
وعلنا ايض كما قلت ان ندرك بان المشكله هي
ان الشيعه والسنه يقاتلون بعضهم البعض منذ
الثمانينات من القر الماضي وهذا هو جوهر
المشكله سيد بسام الجعاره ما رايك في الحل
الذي طرحه ضيفنا من
واشنطن يعني انا ما بعرف كيف امريكا بتصف
نفسها وصيه على الشعوب من قال له اننا
سنقبل بهذا الكلام هذا كلام يعني ليس
جديدا على الاداره الامريكيه نعرف الخطط
او الخرائط التي وضعت منذ زمن طويل وهذا
هو سر الموقف الامريكي من الثوره السوريه
لا توجد حرب طائفيه في سوريا توجد حرب
الان حرب تحرير ضد الغزات الروس ضد الغزات
الايرانيين وقمنا بثوره ضد نظام فاشي اسمه
بشار الاسد ط هذه المكونات الثلاثه سيد
سيد بسام اضف اليها المكون العراقي يعني
الروس اعلنوها صريحه انهم يصنفون تقريبا
كل الفصائل التي تقاتل نظام الاسد بانها
تنظيمات ارهابيه يستوفي ذلك بقى تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه وتنظيم جبهه النصره وجيش
الفتح والقاعده كل التنظيمات تنظيمات
ارهابيه وليس هناك في زعمهم ما يسمى
بالجيش الحر بل يتهكمون على هذا اي افق
ينتظر المعارضه السوريه او المعارضين في
سوريا في ظل هذا الحلف
الرباعي يعني اسمح لي وضح بعض النقاط
ومهمه جدا اولا جاء الرد على كلام لافروف
عن الجيش الحر عند ما تلقى الروس امس ضربه
للعمه اللي بدي اقوله بكل بكل دقه تم
تلقين الروس امس درسا كبيرا تحول ريف حماه
الشمالي الى مقبره الدبابات قتل جنرال
روسي وثلاث روس ونقلوا الى مشفى حما خليني
احكي لك بس على موضوع الصواريخ اللي
انطلقت من بحر قزوين قالت غرفه العمليات
في بغداد انها اصابت 11 هدف في الرقه في
ادلب في حلب اؤكد لك لم يسقط ولا صاروخ في
سوريا وقبل قليل قالت محطه السي ان ان
نقلا عن مسؤول امريكي ان اربع صواريخ سقطت
في ايران بمعنى ان كفاءه غرفه العمليات
ليست افضل من كفاءه الصواريخ الروسيه اطق
26 صاروخ اطلقت من بحر قزوين عندما يسقط
منها اربعه في ايران فهذا لا يعني ان
الصواريخ الباقيه لم تسقط
في صدقني صدقني هي بروباجندا اعلاميه قبل
اليومين قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها
دمرت 12 دبابه لتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في
طرطوس هذا كلام مضحك في طرطوس لا توجد
دوله اسلاميه ولا توجد معارضه ايضا قالت
وزاره الدفاع استنكرت حديث التلفزيون
السوري عن قصف تدمر هناك حاله ارتباك
قالوا انهم دخلوا تركيا بسبب سوء الاحوال
الجويه وقال التلفزيون الروسي ان الجو
ملائم لل للقصف اللي بدي اقوله بكل دقه
هناك محاوله لتهويل حجم الضغط الروسي
العسكري كما قلت لك امس تم تلقين درسا
كبيرا بدليل ان هجومهم اليوم على سال
الغاب كان هجوما باهتا بعد ان تلقوا امس
ضربات كبرى بقول بكل وضوح هم يحاولون
التهويل عسكريا لاجباره على الرضوخ ولكن
الر سيكون
قاسيا ان تبق فاع الامريكي سنتوجه الى
فاصل قصير نناقش بعده الرساله الروسيه
وبخاصه لمن يعنيه الامر في واشنطن من وراء
ضربات صاروخيه عبرت اجواء العراق وايران
ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش تضيعه دور التحالف الروسي العراقي
الايرانيه السوري في تنسيق الهجمات
الروسيه على سوريا وسط غياب اي دور امريكي
واضح اعود بالسؤال للسيد اندري ستيبانوف
الخبير في شؤون الشرق الاوسط وهو ضيفنا من
موسكو سيد ستيبانوف
رئاسه هذا التحالف الاستخباري او مركز
العمليات الاستخباري في مقرها بغداد وهي
دوريه اي كل ثلاثه اشهر يمكن ان يفهم من
هذا ان هذه العمليات ربما او روسيا جاءت
لتبقى وتتمدد ايضا وان هذه العمليات ستطول
وربما تمتد الى خارج سوريا هل هذا الفهم
دقيق لا لا لازن هذا نظام نظام ل المركز
يعني ولكن في اعتقادي حتى انا على اليقين
ان العمليه الروسيه العسكريه لن تدوم فتره
طويله وهي
محدوده حسب التاك وحسب المده وحسب الاهداف
و
اظن ان هذه
الغرفه ياتيه
والمعلوماتيه ستساعد في تسريع انزال
الضربات الملموسه على المنظمات الارهابيه
في العراق وفي سوريا اما بخصوص يعني من
يمكن ان نصفه ارهابين الم يكن رئيس بوش
اكبر الارهابي بعد تدخله في العراق وبعد
مذابح على السبب روسيا تكرر هذا الخطا
مثلا ولا في العراق يعني يعني هذا السبب
روسيا تكرر هذا الخطا هل تتعلم روسيا اصلا
من تاريخها الم الم يقال الم يقل نفس
الكلام الم يقل نفس الكلام عندما تدخل
الاتحاد سوفيتي في افغانستان قبل بضعه
عقود لا كان هذا غلط كان هذا غالط يعني
بدون اي شك اما التدخل الروسي يعني في
اعلى في سوريا يعني هو محدود جدا يعني
محدود ليس هناك اي مقارنه بالوجود
الامريكي على اراضي العراق هناك حوالي
4000 امريكيين يعني في في العراق وهم
عاجزين عن اي شيء يعني يعني الوجود لا
مبرر له يعني اما الوجود الروسي وهو محدود
جدا وهو ظهر انه فعال في مكافحه الداعش
والمنظمات الارهابيه الاخرى طيب سيد جيف
جوردون في في نظر كثيرين تحولت الولايات
المتحده وقيادتها الرئيس اوباما الى مجرد
محللين سياسيين ومراقبين يراقبون الوضع في
سوريا ويقيمون ويعطون النصائح التي
بالتاكيد لن تستمع اليها روسيا هل هذا هو
الدور الامريكي ام ان هناك شيئا ما لا
ندريه او لا يدريه المراقبون للوضع
وامريكا تعد فخا مثلا مثل ما الذي وقعت
فيه موسكو قبل ذلك في
افغانستان
اعتقد بان الصناع القرار والسياسه في
امريكا يشعرون بخيمه الابل لان الخطه التي
جربوها في محاوله تسليح المعارضه السوريه
لم تنجح على الاطلاق وكانت فشلا ذريعا
اعتقد اننا في امريكا ندرك بان هذه محاوله
سيئه من روسيا في محاوله ان تظهر بانها
الطرف الجيد وانها من الاخ عندما تواجه
الارهاب في حين انها تهاجم اناس ليسهم
ارهابيين وانما القوات المعارضه روسيا
تعاو ان تقوم بهذا الامر لعده اسباب اولها
انها تود ان تبقي على اسعار النفط مرتفعه
لان اسعار النفط حاليا منخفضه بشكل كبير
واقتصاد الروسي يعتمد بشكل كبير على الغاز
الطبيعي وعلى النفط واذا تراجت اسعار
النفط فسيخسر الكثير اقتصاديا اذا يودون
رفع اسعار النفط الامر الثاني هو ان روسيا
التي تفرض عقوبات دوليه بشان تدخل نتيجه
تدخلها في اوكرانيا مما ادى الى خساره
الروبل نصف قيم في مقابل الدولار بمعنى
اخر روسيا تعاني بشكل كبير نتيجه العقوبات
الدوليه وانخفاض النفط اذا كان بوتن يمكن
يقنع العالم بانه رجل خير وانه يقاتل
الارهاب فهو بالتالي يود ان يقنع امريكا
واوروبا بان يرفع عنه العقوبات نتيجه
لتدخله في اوكرانيا اذا منجه
فان تحركه يؤكد اولا على ارتفاع اسعار
النفط وربما رافع العقوبات فيما يتعلق
باوكرانيا وسيجعل امريكا واوروبا والعرب
يظهرون ضعافا اذا بالنسبه لبوتين هذه
استراتيجيه رائعه وبالنسبه لبشار الامر
جيد ايضا وكذلك الامر بالنسبه للايرانيين
وبالنسبه لحزبه حزب الله لكنها تمثل كارثه
بالنسبه لكافه الاطراف الاخرى التي تواجهه
سيد بسام جعاره انتم من تلك الجهات
المعنيه في كلام السيد جيف جوردون هل
تتوقعون تحركا امريكيا مضادا لما يحدث في
سوريا ام ان الامر استقر لاصحاب القوه
الحقيقيه على الارض وعني بذلك الروس الذين
حشدوا قوات كبيره في
سوريا يعني سمحلي اقول لك بكل وضوح منذ
اربع سنوات ونحن نكرر عبر شاشتكم وبقيه
الشاشات ان الاداره الامريكيه عدو للشعب
السوري منعت تزويد الشعب السوري بالسلاح
المضاد للطائرات منعت اقامه منطقه امنه
منعت اقامه منطقه حزر جوي سحبت بطاريات
الباتريوت من تركيا تركت تركيا امام ضغط
روسي اللي بقوله بكل وضوح نعرف تماما
حقيقه اهداف الاداره الامريكيه ولكن نحن
نعول على شعبنا باكد لك تماما الذي جرى
امس كان درسا كبيرا للروس ولمن معهم هم
يتحدثون عن ارهابيين ولكنهم جاؤوا تحت
شعار الحرب المقدسه بمعنى انها حرب صليبيه
معلنه هذا الامر يعني اؤكد لك اليوم ان
هناك الاف السوريين سجلوا اسمائهم في
المخيمات للعوده الى سوريا وايضا اؤكد لك
ان الاف الجهاديين سياتون الى سوريا لان
لهم حسابات مع الروس قال اليوم وزير
الدفاع الامريكي كارتر على روسيا ان تتوقع
امرين هجوم في روسيا سوف تتعرض لهجوم وقال
ايضا سوف يكون هناك ضحايا روس على الارض
السوريه باكد لك تماما بان الايام القادمه
ستحمل ستحمل معها الكثير من الانباء
الساره للسوريين نزل الروس الى مغطس لن
يستطيع الخروج منه ضيفك بقول لا يوجد قوات
بريه هناك اكثر من 2000 سور روسي هناك
ايضا 50 طائره ولكن ماذا ستفعل هذه
الطائرات طيب انا د اطرح دعني اطرح السؤال
في عجاله او باختصار على ضيفنا من موسكو
سيد ستيبانوف ساستعرض التي ذكرتها زميلتنا
مريم ابيش في تقريرها الرئيس بوتين الذي
يجيد الكثير من الرياضات هل يجيد السباحه
لكي يستطيع ان يخرج سالما من المستنقع
الذي وضع نفسه فيه بتحليل السيد بسام
الجعاره لا يا لا لا لو يعني بالمقارنه مع
الامريكان الذين اخفقوا في كل شيء في
الشرق الاوسط لا كما قلت يعني التوجد
الروسي محدود جدا واهداف محدده ما موجوده
يعني
والاستراتيجيه و ض حه يعني
[موسيقى]
واما الجيش الحر هناك عف انا انا لم افهم
الاستراتيجيه التي تصفها بواضح ولا يفهمها
كثيرون ما الذي اتى بروسيا من هذا البعد
الهائل الى دوله ليست لها جوار جغرافي مع
روسيا ولا حتى قريبه منها بكل هذه القوات
وبما تقول انه استراتيجيه
التصدي ا التصدي لامريكا اولا انقاذ ما
يمكن نقاز من نظام السوري حمايه الاقليات
حمايه الطائفه العلويه وال الطائف يعني
المسيحيه يعني في اراضي سوريا ومكافحه
الارهاب بشكل فعال
بخلاف هذه استراتيجيه مسكو معلنه التصدي
للولايات المتحده القضاء على التنظيمات
الارهابيه الابقاء على ما تبقى من نظام
بشار الاسد ما
استراتيجياتك
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه كانت تتمثل في
اخراج بشار الاسد من الحكم من خلال كافه
الادوات المتاحه لنا عد استخدام الخيار
العسكري هدفنا ايضا يتمثل في الحاق الاذاء
بتنظيم الدوله والقضايا عليه وبالتالي
قمنا بحمله جواه وشكلنا تحالفا شمل اكثر
من 60 دوله لكن على الاقل 10 دول من هذا
التحالف تشارك في العمليات العسكريه اذا
امريكا تقوم بهذا المجهود في سوريا
والعراق وتقود هذا التحالف القضائي على
تنظيم الدوله في ذات الوقت امريكا قدمت
اسلحه وتدريب للاكراد ليتمكن من مواجهه
تنظيم الدوله في العراق و اعتذر منك على
المقاطعه اشكرك شكرا جزيلا السيد جيف
جوردون المسؤول السابق بوزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه كان معنا من واشنطن واشكر ضيفنا
من لندن الكاتب الصحفي السوري السيد بسام
جعاره ضيفنا من موسكو السيد اندري
ستيبانوف الخبير في شؤون الشرق الاوسط
شكرا جزيلا لكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء بهذا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
نلتقي باذن الله تعالى في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم y